uh vadernock
58
mordant 82
sunak 115
truss 71
two gundat 31
so tom tougandat is eliminated from the
election the other candidates are able
to go forward to a fourth ballot which
will take place tomorrow between 1 and 3
p.m with the results announced at 4pm
thank you very much
well there we are the results of the
third round of polling in the
conservative leadership race and uh very
very interesting indeed rishi sunak has
increased his share of conservative mps
from 101 to 115 penny mordent
stays in second place but actually lost
one vote she's now on 82 having achieved
83 in the previous round list truss has
gone up by seven from 64 to 71. kemi
begnock has gone up by nine from 49 to
58. tom tugan had lost another vote
just above 30 which had been the hurdle
to pass not anymore if you finish bottom
you're out and as you can see there tom
tugan hat is ejected as announced by sir
graham there and the next round the
fourth round of polling it's pretty
relentless this now until they get down
to the last two will take place between
one and three tomorrow after noon with
the result announced at 4 p.m so make a
a note of that for the next stage of
this fascinating race let's get reaction
uh again from our political editor beth
rigby so beth i mean rishi sonak they're
continuing to to build just below the
120 that would have got him through
automatically but penny mordent
dropped a vote
yeah look down but what's interesting
about these results is the person who's
showing the most momentum is actually
rishi sunak and given that it was sawela
bravaman who was on the right of the
party in arch brexiteer
not necessarily the sort of backers that
would fall into the rishi sunak column
his team will be very pleased with that
now he's just five votes off getting to
the final two
tom tugan had eliminated again he lost a
vote
so he didn't put any on he didn't lose
loads though but he's eliminated but as
you said uh
penny mordent you know you didn't expect
penny morden really to pick up votes
from sweller bradman either but for her
to lose a vote here that is not showing
the momentum that her team would want
and she will be disappointed with that
she will be hoping to recover with some
tom tugan heart hat votes in her way but
then liz trusts too i mean liz truss if
this is a moment of momentum she's put
on seven votes kemi badanok did better
than that she's put on nine votes so
kemi badanok actually doing better there
than liz trust so really now you have
morden and trust really slogging it out
for that second spot neither of them
will be particularly happy with that
performance liz trusts slightly closing
the gap on penny mordant but there's
still
11 votes
between them and let's see where the tom
tugan hat votes go in the next round
because as one of morden's supporters
said to me earlier today they think that
they will split between rishi sunak and
penny morden if that happens rishi sunak
is pretty much now nailed on for the
final two and it's going to be an
absolute vicious battle between uh
mordant and liz truss to get through